[Música]
y es el momento de pasar a nuestra
revista de prensa con Marta Moya Marta
Buen día para usted Buenos días Ángela
Pues bien Vamos a comenzar con esta
interesante entrevista que realizó el
medio independiente ruso holloth a una
famosa periodista que mostró sus
inconformidades contra la guerra en
directo al inicio de la invasión y Esto
fue precisamente lo que la hizo muy muy
conocida en todo el mundo Así es Ángela
hablamos de Marina Ocean y cova la
periodista que a principios de marzo del
año pasado interrumpió en la cadena
pública Channel One con ese cartel que
decía par en la guerra No creas en la
propaganda te están mintiendo desde la
realización del informativo tuvieron que
salirse del aire después de que la
periodista interrumpiera en medio del
noticiero y ahora con motivo de que se
cumple un año de ese episodio la
periodista ofrece esta entrevista en la
que bueno se conceden grandes titulares
y muy interesantes no sobre todo pues
cómo logró salir de Rusia y que al la
hora está en Francia no al respecto de
este motivo de cómo huyó del arresto
domiciliario dice oceánicova que poco
antes del juicio fue su propio abogado
quien la le aconsejó huir del país que
antes agentes rusos habían entrado en su
casa a las 6 de la mañana que la
desnudaron la llevaron a un centro de
detención especial y días después la
pusieron bajo arresto domiciliario allí
empezaron a seguirla y cuando
austriacova tomó la determinación de
querer salir del país su ex marido
trabajador de la cadena RT la demandó y
le pidió quitarla patria potestad de sus
dos hijos y dice textualmente mi ex
esposo me quitó a mi hija y no la soltó
dijo que yo era una mala influencia le
dijo tu madre es una criminal nunca más
la verás
es decir que hasta el momento no tiene
la custodia de sus hijos pero
ciertamente la historia no acaba aquí no
quién más no Ángela porque después la
niña a través de una aplicación de taxis
logró zafarse de su padre y logró llegar
hasta Marina oceánico hasta hasta su
madre sin embargo la huida del país se
retrasó hasta el mes de octubre porque
la niña no tenía pasaporte por todo este
lío legal con el padre y al final
tuvieron que contactar con reporteros
Sin fronteras que fue la organización
que las ayudó a salir del país dice
oceánico va que no puede decir por qué
país salieron pero que solo tenían dos
días para salir desde Moscú fuera del
país dice Tal cual cambiamos siete veces
de carro el último se quedó atascado en
el barro tuvimos que caminar hasta un
kilómetro de la frontera pero nos
perdimos pero por un campo arado
teníamos una escolta pero la conexión
celular no funcionaba y estaba buscando
un camino literalmente por la
disposición de las estrellas finalmente
vieron cruzar a la guardia fronteriza se
tuvieron que esconder y en algún momento
comencé a pensar que lo mejor era volver
a Moscú e ir a la cárcel que dar un paso
más no pero es que es impresionante Cómo
se nos extorsiona con nuestras
maternidades y algo que no tiene nada
que ver y que es completamente político
Pero al final de toda esta historia
terrorífica la periodista acaba en
Francia y este es una historia que
también nos cuenta en la entrevista Así
es porque el periodista le pregunta
decidió ir a Francia por invitación de
macron y oceánicoba dice que
evidentemente macron Después del
episodio en la televisión rusa le
ofreció ir a Francia pero que en ese
momento oceánico va declinó la oferta es
sin embargo acabó allí porque la sede de
reporteros Sin fronteras está en París y
al final acabó pidiendo asilo político
en este país dice literalmente Francia
me salvó la vida no solo a mí también a
mi hija y preguntaba sobre si es si se
arrepiente asegura que no se arrepiente
pero que es incapaz de revivir ese
momento sobre todo en vídeo y sobre si
mantiene contacto con sus compañeros del
canal dice que no porque
los servicios de inteligencia ruso
duplicaron su tarjeta SIM y tomaron
represalias contra esos compañeros que
le habían mostrado apoyo a Ángela bueno
continúa represión a la prensa y después
de esta historia Marta que no sé si lo
dijimos a propósito que ella nació en
odesa y luego se radicó en Rusia Pero
bueno vamos a cambiar de tema con otra
de las cuestiones que ha marcado mucho
la agenda informativa de las últimas
horas y es la caída de este drone
estadounidense en el mar Negro de
Estados Unidos en el pentágono dicen que
fue un jet ruso que golpeó la hélice y
lo tumbó Rusia dice que eso no fue así
qué es lo que dice la prensa rusa Pues
sí Ángela como siempre versiones
encontradas vamos con la prensa rusa con
el coso moscaya Prada que dice que tras
toda esta polémica es bastante obvio
cito textualmente que los drones no
estaban de excursión y que este tipo de
dispositivos realizan misiones de
combate en interés de nuestro enemigo
sostiene que el dron estadounidense se
colocó a una distancia indecentemente
cerca a las fronteras rusas esto es 60
kilómetros también recogemos una nota de
la agencia Tas de noticias la agencia
rusa que recoge las palabras del
embajador en Washington anatoli antonov
que emitió ayer un comunicado a razón de
todo este episodio y que decía
textualmente Qué hacen estos drones a
miles de millas de Estados Unidos La
respuesta es obvia reúnen inteligencia
que luego utiliza el régimen de kiev
para atacar nuestro territorio bueno por
supuesto los medios estadounidenses
También dan su propia versión sobre el
tema no por supuesto empezamos con the
Gil rápidamente que dice preocupaciones
por una posible escalada del conflicto
es el primer caso conocido públicamente
en el que un avión de combate ruso daña
deliberadamente dice de Gil un dron
estadounidense dice que el vuelo del mq
reaper estaba en un vuelo rutinario y no
que no tenía otra intención y por otra
parte destacamos a vox.com que dice que
los aviones de Rusia y Estados Unidos ya
han tenido en otras momentos de la
historia
episodios y altercados pero que la
guerra nucrania al final Les lleva un
momento de distensión sin embargo el
episodio marca como la inestabilidad en
Ucrania amenaza constantemente con
desbordarse ya sea por error o por
provocación pues Marta así tenemos que
cerrar ella nuestra revista de prensa
por el día de hoy una lástima porque nos
faltó un tema por abordar pero le
agradezco y nos vemos mañana Gracias